if the rich aren't making all of their
extra money and we actually have a
graphic that shows how much wealthier
the top quintile is getting as the for
lesser quintiles are losing their share
of the income where is that getting
taken from how come they're losing this
much income so I think if you look at
the two two theories of income
inequality one is that the rich the
halves are negotiating with the
have-nots it's a zero-sum pie to the
extent one guy negotiates more the other
person gets less it's the classic
managers against against labor a second
way is that they're actually earning the
one percent of successful earning their
success by coming up with innovations
and things like Apple and Google that
are valuable and that's actually putting
upward pressure on wages and there's an
independent set of forces which are
putting downward pressure on wages
things like immigration open trade
borders and such and so if you can fleet
the two and blame the success of the one
percent for what's happening to the
stagnant wages of the middle class you
want to attach them and redistribute the
money but you're slowing down the very
thing which is putting upward pressure
on wages and if you don't solve the
other problem you're left with the thing
that's putting downward pressure on
wages you can get slower growth even
negative wages under that that
circumstance and so they're putting
together their conflating the two but
they're making very little argument why
the two would be completed other than
the pic of the argument which is it's
just a negotiation between the haves and
have-nots well I'll leave that debate to
our viewers at home but recommend that
they read your book unintended
consequences to get a better idea to
form a better thesis for themselves